I get it why I get the party lid outside
LeBron James is showing off his dance
moves he's gotta watch he's got to stay
tuned and keep you here city streets and
it's all thanks to his 12 year old son
Bryce who is becoming a rising star on
tick-tock on Monday he enlisted his
basketball star dad for his latest
choreographed dance I get him come I get
him why I get to party Lee not to be
outdone on social media LeBron's
youngest child has also been absolutely
thriving five-year-old daughter Zuri
already boasts 130,000 subscribers on
YouTube and she recently posted a baking
video with her dad that has received
more than 1.3 million views thank you
for letting me be on your YouTube
channel
I appreciate you that has a little
finishing touch yeah that's a little bit
of touching on top instead of a cherry
on top
I love joking around and laughing with
my friends and family every single day
you know and I hate being alone so that
may be something that may be surprising
to people I don't like being alone I
like my friends and my family and my
kids and everybody better than an
entourage so that's a different kind of
entourage that's more like you know a
unique bond a fam tirage I just came out
with a new word
I like that Fanta rise
[Music]